the town of san remy has a long history
it began as the graco roman city of
glanum
after julius caesar conquered the
provence for the roman empire
it then became known as provincia nostra
our province since it was literally the
first province that rome was able to
acquire beyond the alps
the town of glanum was soon thriving and
was given a special honor
they were all given roman citizenship
its wealth is still visible in several
monuments located just outside the
asylum of
which suggests that vincent must have
seen them
among others here is a mausoleum built
in about 30 bc by three brothers to
honor their parents who were members of
the julia family
nearby is a roman triumphal arch with
exquisite carvings of fruit and flowers
that were probably harvested in the
fields and orchards nearby
the sides depict prisoners of war
perhaps to commemorate caesar's conquest
after the roman city was destroyed in
260 a.d
the survivors moved north to build a new
town that became san remi de provence
in the 11th century augustinian monks
built a monastery that in the 18th
century
became a convalescent home
even in roman times
glanum had a reputation as a wellness
resort for both spiritual and physical
renewal
only a quarter of the rooms were
occupied at the time which gave vincent
the peace and quiet he so desperately
needed
theo was actually able to secure two
rooms for him
one room to sleep
[Music]
and another to use as a studio
[Music]
that sense of serenity
of an almost monastic calm
was still very much in the air
you know that's why vincent was very
fortunate to be able to come here
because other asylums in france were
rather horrific places where the insane
lived in truly appalling conditions but
you know this raises an important
question and it's a question that has
never been fully resolved
what was wrong with vincent
was he
insane
as we saw
dr ray of the hotel du and oral
diagnosed epilepsy
the attending physician in sarimi
dr theophile perro
agreed with him
he wrote
the patient is suffering from acute
mania with hallucinations of sight and
hearing that caused him to mutilate
himself by cutting off his ear
at the moment he seems to have recovered
his reason
but he does not feel that he has the
strength and the courage to live by
himself
and has voluntarily asked to be admitted
to this institution
it is my opinion that monsieur van gaach
is subject to epileptic fits at
infrequent intervals and that he needs
to be kept under prolonged observation
this diagnosis was affirmed when dr
peyron learned of the history of
epilepsy on vincent's maternal side
but in modern times this assessment has
come under attack
for one it doesn't take into account
many of the symptoms that vincent
himself cites over and over again in his
letters
such as his alcoholism
his poor digestion and stomach problems
his insomnia
his moments of intense anxiety
as well as his history of syphilis
other aggravating factors were poor
hygiene
and an inclination to starve himself at
times
[Music]
some years ago as a professor in the
school of psychology at feeling graduate
university
i led a research project to try to
diagnose vinson's condition
i enlisted a group of clinical
psychology students who were working on
their phds
and asked them to analyze vincent's
letters from the noonan period onwards
on the strength of that evidence
they ruled out a number of previous
diagnoses including epilepsy
schizophrenia or schizoaffective
disorder
instead and astonishingly
all of these students arrived
independently at the same diagnosis
that vincent presented with clear
symptoms of clinical depression
as well as a bipolar disorder of
moderate severity
they noted that depression or
melancholia as it was called at the time
ran in both sides of the van gogh family
in fact vincent's sister wilhelmine
was committed to an asylum at age 40
and remain there for the rest of her
life
it may also explain why so many of
vincent's uncles including uncle scent
suffered from poor health
what's more the bipolar condition
aggravated by alcoholism and a poor diet
explains why vincent could suffer
manic episodes one moment
and then be perfectly calm and lucid to
next am not properly speaking mad
because my mind is absolutely clear at
times
but it is horrible during the attacks
when i completely lose consciousness
that may also explain
why vincent cut off his left ear
today we know that bipolar patients have
a high inclination for self-harm
as many as 30 to 40 percent of bipolar
patients are known to have hurt
themselves at some point
what's more
as many as six percent of these patients
will die by suicide so when you put all
this together
bipolar disorder seems to be a very
plausible diagnosis for vincent's
condition
[Music]
of course
in the 19th century no one had ever
heard of this condition
and in fact even today psychologists
don't really know what causes it
certainly genetics play a role which was
definitely the case in vincent's family
but social conditions are an important
factor as well
from the moment
vincent was introduced into the demi
mold of paris society he was on a roller
coaster of alcohol abuse particularly in
drinking up sand which was cheap but
potentially deadly
in fact it was found to be such a
dangerous and addictive drug
that it was banned from much of europe
as well as america
another key factor in bipolar patients
is stress and from his letters we know
that vincent was well aware of the
financial burden he placed on his
brother this in turn produced an intense
pressure to succeed commercially as an
artist
but even if vincent's condition had been
accurately diagnosed
there would not have been any reliable
treatment at the time
even today there is no real cure or
preventive
other than
antidepressants
and perhaps the use of antipsychotics
when the patient is having a manic
episode
of course
none of these were available in
vincent's time
instead
he and other patients were treated with
hydrotherapy
twice a week
in both hot and cold water
the bathtubs
are still in place today
now i take a bath twice a week and stay
in it for two hours
my stomach is infinitely better than a
year ago so as far as i know
i just have to continue
and so vincent settled in and soon
discovered that the serenity promised by
the institution
was often elusive
day and night the air was filled with
shouting and howling as though from a
group of caged animals as he wrote
but he tried to make the best of it
i have a little room with gray green
paper and two water green curtains with
designs of pale roses and thin lines of
blood red
the curtains are actually very pretty
though probably left by some ruined rich
man now deceased
from the same source most likely comes a
very worn armchair
the windows of his room
were barred as in a prison cell but
remarkably vincent only had eyes for the
view beyond
through the iron barred window i see a
square field of wheat in an enclosure
a perspective like a van going
above which i see the sun rise in all
its glory
eventually he began to explore the
asylum itself
including the long corridors of the
monastery and the pretty garden in the
courtyard
with a small fountain in the center
his studies of irises and plants in the
garden
show a notable shift in his palette
the exuberant orange and yellows of the
oral period
have given way to a new emphasis on more
somber colors
vincent was well aware of it
when i dream in my best moments i don't
see striking color effects as much as
halftones
what's interesting
is the painstaking detail with which
vincent painted the irises almost as if
he wants to prove to himself that he is
fully capable of dissecting such a small
subject with such clarity
the frenzy of slashing paint on the
canvas is nowhere in evidence
vincent is working in a more deliberate
fashion
perhaps in an effort to
regain his mental balance
on june 5th
dr perron dean vinson to have
sufficiently recovered to allow him to
roam freely in the immediate vicinity of
the asylum but time and again
vincent was drawn to this hypnotic image
of a field in an enclosure that he had
first seen from his window
he now painted it
at eye level
in the foreground is a wheat field
flattened and laid to waste by a storm
beyond the wall is a gray foliage of
some olive trees
some cottages and the hills
and on top of the canvas a large white
and gray cloud drowning in the azure sky
with the onset of summer
and the scintillating heat rising from
the earth vincent's view of nature began
to change
under his hands the orchards and
cypresses were gradually transformed as
if captured by a nervous intensity
it seems as if all of creation is caught
up in a powerful storm the same storm
that some believe was raging in vinson's
mind
the skies the fields the torch-like
cypresses all seem possessed by this
strange cosmic energy
the earth is in turmoil
nature
in flames
but when we look deeper
it seems that this distortion is
deliberate for the composition itself
still unfolds along classical and
symmetrical lines
[Music]
the violent colors too seem calculated
to balance each other out
the gold of ripe wheat versus the cold
blue of the sky
the shimmering green of cypresses versus
the neutral gray of the olive trees
so he made a few paintings in the spring
summer early summer and he
had an attack
and then he started again painting in
september for him olive grove was a very
important symbol as well to stay in the
south of france and cyprus's olive
groves
all peel the
and so you find a lot of these typical
uh southern french symbols in a way for
him they were symbols in his paintings
that's why the suggestion that these
tortured forms were a direct expression
of vincent's tormented mind
is not plausible
[Music]
instead when vincent looked at these
landscapes he truly experienced them as
nature in motion
and that's the way he painted it
in this reaper
a vague figure fighting like a devil in
the midst of the heat to get to the end
of his task
i see the image of death
in the sense that humanity
might be the wheat he's reaping
it is during this time that vincent
painted the masterpiece from his sorremi
period
which today is the pride of the museum
of modern art in new york
the starry night
as we saw previously vincent was deeply
interested in the subtle tints of the
night and he tried to capture them with
any color other than black
and now from his window at the asylum he
could see a night in all of its spectral
splendor
without any gas light seeping into his
view
i don't think we'll ever be able to see
what vincent saw
since the invention of electric light
our towns and cities have forever washed
away the purity of night as the 19th
century saw it
back then
on a clear night you could see the milky
way in all of its splendor arcing across
the sky on a bed of crystal clear stars
that's what vinson saw and that's what
he painted in this gorgeous painting
the awesome majesty
of a summer night in provence
once again he used a very traditional
composition
a freeze-like horizontal view of the
village with the alpil mountains beyond
anchored on the left by towering
cypresses
and on the right
by the crescent moon
[Music]
this morning at some time before sunrise
i saw the country from my window with
nothing but the morning star
[Music]
there are a few strange notes in this
painting
for example the church with its
exaggerated tall spire
there is no such church in saarimi and
in fact such spires are a typical motif
of the north so what vincent did is
insert a memory from his time in nunen
which shows once again how much his
years in holland were on his mind as he
spent time in the south
it also suggests that this painting was
not done on the spot
like the starry night over the ron that
he painted in oral
but back in his little studio at the
asylum
as with any work that would become as
famous as starry night
all sorts of creative theories have been
offered to explain the intense power
of this painting
for example meyer shapiro argued that
the stars in the painting
refer to revelation 12
and a great sign appeared in heaven
a woman clothed with the sun with the
moon under her feet
and on her head a crown of twelve stars
of course
based on his bible studies vincent would
undoubtedly have been familiar with this
verse
but you have to wonder why he didn't say
so in his letters that describe the work
similarly the writer lauren soth
sees in this painting a sublimated image
of van gogh's deepest religious feelings
but such interpretations ignore the fact
that by this time vincent had become
disillusioned with religious ideas
others again see in the swirling stars
an impression of galaxies such as the
famous whirlpool galaxy which was well
known at the time
some believe it speaks of a yearning for
the afterlife
well you know
for me the matter is quite simple
starry night
captures vincent's simple wonder at the
magnificent beauty and infinity of the
universe
nothing more
and nothing less
and surprisingly it seems that vincent
was not very happy with the work
even though in the years to come it
would help to secure his fame
in one letter
he wrote
once again i allowed myself to be led
astray into reaching for stars that are
too big
another failure and i've had my fill of
that
a failure
hardly
today starry night is justifiably
considered
the greatest work
of his time in san remy
[Music]
nonetheless his mental condition
remained fragile and four times he
suffered a manic attack
during one such episode in july he
nearly poisoned himself by swallowing
his paints
it took him several weeks to recover
from this episode
and when he finally did he painted what
he saw in the mirror
[Music]
i began the first day i got up
i was thin and pale as the devil
[Music]
in february of 1890
vincent once more suffered a devastating
attack
it was so severe that it took him
several months to recover
his art now betrays the strain the
fatigue and the anxiety of this
difficult time
in response
vincent groped for models to try to
regain his creative balance
he reverted to a practice from his early
dutch period
working after prince by his beloved
artist jean francois mille
as well as prince by domie
and de la croix
but then spring returned and vincent
became restless
having now suffered four attacks at the
asylum
it became clear to him that living here
would not offer a cure
in fact
being around people who were verifiably
insane got on his nerves
he insisted on going back to paris
even though theo was now a married man
not only that but just a few months
earlier on january 31st
joe had given birth to a son
the baby was named vincent willem
after his uncle
what was to be done with vincent
how to resolve this dilemma
fortunately this is where camille
pissarro
came to vinson's rescue
[Music]